since reduction so today I'll be talking
about the problem of proving so-called
basis claps theorems for holographic
logarithms overall demain sizes so I
guess I'll start off with sort of a
brief introduction to material that I'm
guessing a lot of people nicely familiar
with but just an intro to match gates
and holographic algorithms right so
again we'll be working with Theory match
gates in which we sort of want to reduce
given counting problems to the problem
counting perfect matchings in planar
graphs so the problem County Park
matching is an arbitrary graphs we know
it to be sharp you complete but when we
restrict our graphs to be planner then
the problem is easy and roughly speaking
the reason is that this perfect matching
polynomial ends up being basically the
same as the the foffy in polynomial for
corresponding graphs adjacency matrix
and we sort of the only discrepancy as
we have this sort of sign that is
associated to each perfect matching but
it turns out that for planar graphs we
can sort of orient the edges in such a
way that these signs sort of go away and
the toffee and ends up agreeing with the
perfect match polynomial and then the
fact that the fafi end is merely the
square root of the determinant of the
adjacency matrix is enough for us to
sort of compute the number perfect
matchings in polynomial time all right
so now let's just take a sample counting
problem say we have some boolean formula
and we want to count the number of
satisfying assignments and for our
purposes let's just imagine that this
formula happens to be planner so if we
draw the corresponding bipartite graph
we're on the left-hand side we have the
variables and on the right-hand side we
have the clauses and we draw the
corresponding edges let's just assume
for now that this for instructor
purposes this graph is planar and
furthermore let's just you know let's
restrict our attention to the case where
every variable appears at most twice in
the formula and each clause you know
accepts the girls
alright so let's sort of imagine that
each satisfying assignments or
corresponds to they're sending a yes or
no signal along each of these serve
intermediate wires and so I guess I'll
denote these by green if the variable
the corresponding variables assigned
true and black if it's not and we sort
of have two constraints on the
assignments to these wires that sort of
yields a satisfying assignment to this
formula the first is that every time
area below peers the signal that it sort
of sends has to be consistent in other
words the out of any given vertex on the
left the two signal descends must either
both be green or both be black and we
sort of note this with this search
signature vector likewise you know we
want this to be a satisfying assignment
so every clause has to have at least one
true and again we sort out this with
this signature so there's at least one
one among the if there's at least one
true signal among the three incoming
signals then we sort of say we like it
okay and the idea to reduce to the
problem perfect matchings in finer
graphs is to serve and code these
signatures using the matching properties
of graphs so a match gate is basically
just a weighted graph with some special
subset of vertices called external nodes
and we'll say that the number of those
external nodes is the so-called arity of
this match grade and the center
signature of this match gate is going to
be basically the vector which consists
let's say indexed by subsets of those
external nodes and so for each subset we
look at the number of perfect matchings
of the sub graph we get after we remove
that subset
so this is called the standard signature
so as an example this elementary but
okay so if these are the two external
loads of this match gate then we get the
following standard signature likewise
you can check this is also true and the
idea is if we can find standard match
gates player match gates which have the
standard signatures corresponding to the
consistency and satisfaction constraints
then basically all I want to do is you
know replace every one of these vertices
on the left with a match gauge who
standard signature is the you know
encodes the SAT the consistency
constraint and everything on the right
replace with a match gate which has
standard signature encoding the
satisfaction constraint and if we can do
this then we sort of okay now let's look
at all possible you know assignments to
these wires this is one such and we look
at how many you know perfect matchings
of this new bigger graph we obtained
when these wires in green are present in
the graph well if these wires are in
green are present in the graph then
their endpoints can't be are sort of
omitted from the corresponding match
gates and so if we want to come the
perfect matchings of this this new match
grid we look at the corresponding
entries in the standard signatures of
the generators when the endpoints are
removed from those generators and
likewise when the endpoints are we from
the recognizers and we sort multiply all
these entries together and we get the
number perfect we get the number of
perfect matchings in which these green
edges are present and the point is that
in this way we serve established by
ejection between the number of perfect
matchings of this new bigger graph and
the number of sort of satisfying
assignments to our original problem but
the bad news is that the satisfaction
vector sort of has no match planner
match gate that has the corresponding
standard signature and again the reason
is the sort of parity thing where a
graph with a non reverses has no perfect
matching so for a given standard
signature
only the indices of one particular
parody will have entries that are not
zero and sort of the saving grace so
this is all sort of the pre holographic
stuff so the actual do nothing part is
where we apply the so-called basis
change so let's think of this perfect
matching sort of as an inner product of
vectors in the following way so we're
going to sum over all possible to to the
W assignments to the wires and then
we'll look at the corresponding indices
that are the corresponding vertices in
the generators and the recognize knives
that are removed and as I said before
what we're going to do is we're going to
take the corresponding entries in the
Santa signatures and so multiply them
together for any given assignment to the
wires and we take the sum of products
and this is essentially just the inner
product of the following two tensor
products so this G is just going to be a
particular tensor product of all the
standard signatures of generators and
this R is going to be the tensor product
of the santa cruz with recognizers where
the order is specified served by the
configuration of the wires and you can
also think of this inner product sort of
as sort of a dual vector being applied
to a pilot vector in the following way
we can regard this this tensor product
of all the standard signatures of the
generators as an element in situ the two
to the W and will regard the recognizer
tensor as an element in the dual space
and now this perfect match a polynomial
the center product is just you apply the
dual vector R to the final vector G and
the point of holographic algorithms is
that this is independent of the choice
of basis for X so in particular now
let's sort of apply a change of basis so
given the 2 by 2 basis matrix define the
signature with respect to that basis
matrix for a generator to be the vector
g which satisfies this equation so in
some sense it's the coefficients under
this new basis and likewise for the
recognizer apply a sort of the dual
basis change and we'll say the signature
with
to this basis for a recognizer and it's
going to be the vector RSS fabulous the
point is that now if we find match gates
which have a sort of these signatures
then we're sort of still home free and
we can still compute the number
satisfying assignments in polynomial
time and so this can't be done over the
complex numbers and it can't be done
over a boolean domain but over you know
mod seven famously we have sort of an
explicit example of a basis and
corresponding standard signatures so
that over the space asst the
corresponding signatures are precisely
the consistency and satisfaction
constraint so in other words counting
planner read twice monotone three s3c
NFS mod seven is easy so and the
particular match gates that have those
standard signatures are the ones I serve
gave earlier okay so this is that was a
very brief introduction to match gates
and holographic algorithms so now let me
get on to the focus of a stock which is
on sort of the two main parameters that
we serve deal with in holographic
algorithms one is the so-called basis
size and one is the so-called domain
size all right so the domain size is
essentially the range of values that are
you know given counting problem can take
on so if we're working over domain size
to which we have been so far this deals
with problems like counting bullying
satisfying assignments vertex covers
perfect matchings ice problems but more
generally over domain size K we can ask
you know what's counts the number of feo
que coloring sub graph a subject to
certain constraints right so domain size
is just the number of colors you have
ok so what changes over domain size
queen size k is that now our signatures
with respect to a given matrix are now
vectors dimension K to the end the point
is that all the incoming edges to a
vertex can now take on not just two
values but K values and so we sort of FK
to the end possible combinations very
end incoming edges and now by this you
know these definitions of signatures
with respect to a given matrix given
basis we see that this just by comparing
you know the dimensions of the matrices
we see that the basis matrix now has to
have with K so how do we handle this
introduction of K colors instead of just
two colors so in the main size ka equals
two case we sort of encoded each color
each of the two colors sort of by the
presence or the absence of an external
node so when this wire is green when you
know the corresponding value in our
boolean formula for a variable is set to
be true then we sort of say ok this this
vertex we remove if it's set to be false
then we sort of include this vertex all
right so that was sort of how we encoded
colors in the main size two case and
more generally if we have some wider
range of colors what we're going to do
is instead of encoding by the presence
or absence of you know one external node
we're going to do the presence or
absence of some subset of L external
nodes and in other words now when we
work with now we're going to work with
sort of blocks of L nodes and so the
number of external nodes forgiven match
k is going to be some multiple of this
parameter l and intuitively you should
think of l is kind of like the number of
bits you need to encode of the K colors
and so what changes now well as i said
the parodies of these match gates are
now going to be multiples of l the
external nodes are going to be grouped
into blocks of l where the wires between
match gates are connected block-wise and
because you know we want to still
satisfy these relations we see that now
this basis matrix has to be a
22 the L and so to summarize you need
basis of dimensions to to the L by K and
we're going to call this L to base of
size so the sort of basic question that
we want to address is for a given domain
given domain size of problems what is
the smallest basis size you need in
order to sort of solve all possible
problems simulate all possible
holographic algorithms over that domain
size so that's the subject of this talk
and so to start off we're going to first
make some yep preliminary so here's some
pool area set up we're going to regard
these standard signatures no longer as
vectors but as matrices where the TF
matrix form of a standard signature
basically you're going to take all the
external nodes in block T and you look
at all possible to to the L combinations
to slay all subsets of those external
external nodes and those are going to be
the sort of rows of our matrix and the
columns are going to be sort of the
possible subsets of the remaining
external nodes so we're basically just
rien rien rien re-indexing our standard
signature vector into this matrix form
and we do the same thing for you know
these signature vectors with respect to
a given basis so instead of a k to the n
vector it's going to be a K by K to the
N minus 1 matrix and throughout all
denote bro indices by superscripts and
column indices by subscripts and so the
technical assumption that will make in
this work is that so we have this term
called full rank so we say that a
generator is a full rank if there exists
some block t for which the rank of that
TF matrix form of g is going to be k if
it's full rank and so the reason we make
this assumption well in the case of
domain size 2 if our holographic
algorithm doesn't use any full rank
signatures then
it turns out that you know this
holographic algorithm in some sense is
trivial this is not necessarily true in
the case of domain size K but this is
sort of a technical assumption that
would be making throughout and we can
check that well it turns out that we can
assume also that the spaces matrix is
also a full rank and that this identity
holds I'm so particular we're going to
be working in the setting where the the
standard signature matrix oops the
standard signature matrix is always
going to be a rank K for some lochte so
the question will deal with is give it
give it a domain size K what is the
smallest basis size l for which any
holographic algorithm over this domain
size which has a full rank match gate
can be simulated by one over basis size
l so back in 08 a long time ago over a
domain size 2 we so tie a tie and LU
show that we actually only need a basis
item of one in other words all we need
to do to consider you know holographic
algorithms all the bully demand is to
look at basis matrices that are
two-by-two matrices and this led to a
beautiful line of work sort of
classifying the structural theory of you
know I'll graphic algorithms over drain
size two and more recently it was shown
that over domain size of three and four
you correspondingly need-based size one
or two so in other words Ruta main size
three you need a to buy three base
matrix over domain size for you need
sort of a four by four and more
generally there is conjecture that over
to my size K you need for function of
log base two of K and so the intuition
for this locked FK again is that the
space the size you sort of think of as
the number of bits you need to encode
your K colors but the real surprise is
that you know this floor function
appears so you don't actually need all
log to the 2k bits in order to actually
encode all these colors and so in
independent works mingjie and I showed
that this conjecture zactly true
and so in the stock i'll focus on my
approach which is through serve more
algebraic techniques and so let me just
first give a sketch of the argument
right so first some technical definition
let's say some subset of the end length
n bit strings is called the cluster if
we can sort of think of it as some
collection of the bits are fixed and the
rest are allowed to sort of very so we
serve right the set of indices that are
allowed to vary let's say there are some
positions p1 through p.m. and we sort of
write this cluster as some fixed string
plus these strings EP 12 EP M or e I
serve denotes the bit string which is
all zeros except at the I position in
which it's a 1 ok so for example this
cluster is 0 0 0 0 0 1 1 0 0 1 0 1 is a
cluster which we can write as 0 0 0 plus
you know will be allowed positions 1 and
3 2 very sorry for you wait another good
yeah yeah so we sort of think of a
cluster all right so I guess I'll just
try to go through this example so in
this case we see that in all four
strings the the position that sort of
stays the same is the second position in
which we have all zeros but the other
two positions sort of range over all
possible bit strings of length to write
this cluster that we do know it as
follows
you're allowed to add 0 0 0 + 0 0 0 you
don't have to anyone or 30 yeah so I
guess this notation so the e 1 e 3 it's
just saying that the option yes so you
take some subset of the positions and
then yeah yeah yeah all right so the the
rough outline we have sort of three
steps the main ingredient is you want to
show that any standard signature of rank
at least choose to the K so to start
with let's let's assume for now that
we're in the setting where the domain
size is the power of 2 and I'll say
later why this can generalize to ulta
mean sizes and so what we want to show
is that any standard signature of rank
at least this domain size contains a
cluster of linearly independent rows 2
to the K linearly independent rows all
right so this is one ingredient the next
is basically that you know inverting
standard signatures in some sense also
gives us standard signatures inverting a
sense of matrix multiplication and
lastly I'll show how these two
ingredients sort of allow us to simulate
using a smaller basis size right so in
some sense step one is kind of the
technical core of this proof step two is
adapted from a previous result in serve
an alternative formulation of match
gates character theory and this
stimulation step is due to time foo in
their proof for the collapse theorem
over domain sizes 3 and 4 so 2 and 3 are
sort of essentially they've already been
done so i'll serve try to speed through
these all right so the property
basically i want to say that full rank
tuzhel k by 2 to the N minus 1 K
standard signatures have right in versus
under matrix multiplication which are
also standard signatures so I can
somehow somehow the standard signature
is kind of form a group of
multiplication and the proof that the
inshaa had is essentially as follows so
given some imagicate we want to kind of
invert it so
we're going to serve attached match
gates on the left and right which reduce
its standard signature to one that's
effectively a smaller match gate destroy
it you Ninh with this separate edge and
how do we invert this new match gate
well basically we know inductively that
the smaller magic 8 has some inverse and
now we just depend know the separate
destroyed edge from it and if we connect
these which corresponds to matrix
multiplication then we get the identity
so in some so in some sense to get the
script property all we're doing is
induction with some clever row and
column operations right so that's the
group property and so how do you use
sort of cluster existence and group
property to get the ax class result so
by cluster existence ok let's first pick
out a generator with a full rank
signature and let's find a cluster of
call of row indices let's call it Z and
now let's index into the rows of our
basis matrix via the sea to obtain a
smaller basis matrix and I claim that i
can use the smaller basis matrix which
is of the desired basis size of log base
2 of K for the simulation and so for
each generator I'm going to sort of
construct these new generators as
follows I'm going to take the Z and
index into each of the blocks via that Z
and I'm only going to keep as external
nodes those nodes which are indexed by Z
ok so the red ones are correspond to
this cluster z and I'm just going to
keep those as external nodes and the
rest all sort of regard as internal to
the magic eight I denote this by g star
Z and similarly I'm going to take this G
compliment tz2 be the match gate where
in all but block t I'm still going to
keep only those external nodes index by
Z as external nodes button block t I'm
going to keep everything as an external
node all right so there's just some some
new map case that
create out of all the existing
generators and it turns out that these
generators with respect to the smaller
matrix basis matrix m superscript Z have
the they sort preserve the original
signatures that our generators have and
now we want to say you know in some
sense to achieve recognizers which have
the same original recognizer signatures
I want to somehow say i can divide this
m to the z out of my original matrix m
so the question is is this new thing a
valid standard signature of a recognizer
well this is where the group property
comes in let's define this new thing t
which is m / MZ and by construction this
so this generator here sort of satisfies
the following identity this T sort of
allows us to transform between the two
match gates that I showed earlier and
now if I take this T and I move it to
the other side then actually conclude
that the recognizers I need are
precisely I take the original match gate
and I attach sort of this transducer T
and the point is that the original
signatures that we had our sort of
preserved so this is sort of a very fast
account of this kind of approach but
suffice to say that cluster existence
and grew and grew property are enough to
give us the clap theorem and so now I
guess in the writing time i'll try to
sketch the the proof of cluster
existence which is sort of like the main
contribution of this work and the the
key ingredient is this thing i'd call
rag rigidity
so the surprising thing that sort of
lies at the heart of this floor function
log base 2 of k is this fact that's if
you take any standard signature in
matrix form the rank is always a power
of 2 and so intuitively why is that gave
us the slower function it serves as okay
if we're working over domain size let's
say 10 we actually get collapsed as good
as over domain size 8 so instead of just
collapsing to log base 2 of 10 we
collapse 2 3 which is floor function of
log base 2 of 10 ok so this rank
rigidity is sort of the main ingredient
and how do we prove this we're going to
use an algebra technique based on sort
of the so-called match gate identities
so it turns out there's a necessary and
sufficient characterization of the
standard signatures of match gates so we
have this hideous looking sort of set of
quadratic polynomial equations that the
entries of sandwich assure is satisfy no
need to look further into you know what
this is let me just extract out sort of
the most useful facts about these
identities so first of all let me so let
me draw your attention to the plus or
minus that's in these identities it
turns out that this plus or minus will
depend serve on the value of T and sort
of for now let's just abstract that out
and just say you know a matrix is a
pseudo signature if these ideas hold up
to a sign of plus or minus so this is
just some technical thing we're kind of
being lazy and we want to ignore this
and so seriously pseudo signatures can
include no ordinary standard signatures
and they also conclude if we index into
a particular cluster of rows that will
still give us a co-signature if we take
the transpose we still get a co
signature so just some high bar official
thing that makes life a bit easier so
what are these masks identities tell us
well let's consider a really basic
example so what you're looking at here
is some subset some sub matrix of the
same signature matrix where the row
indices are sure here in Colin Macy's
here
and let's assume that the parody of the
number of external nodes is such that
these entries happen to be zeros and
what the mask identity corresponds to
this really tells us is that the two by
two matrix index in green shown the left
is up to a sign equal to the 2 by 2
determinant right so in other words in
some sense if we look at these two
columns 1 1 0 0 and 1 111 the two by two
miners if the two by two miners between
these two columns I'll vanish then the
two by two miners between these two
columns also all vanish in particular
the rose sorry I guess I said yeah so
the rows 1 1 0 0 and 1 111 are linearly
dependent if sort of the intermediate
rows 1 1 0 1 and 1 110 or linearly
dependent more generally one can show
that you know if we have some rows say
all zeros and all ones then we look at
all possible pairs where we swap out a
zero for one on the left and a 140 on
the right and if all these pairs are
mutually linearly dependent then the
original rows are also linearly
dependent so this is really all we
really need out of match gate identities
and as I'll explain in some sense it
tells us that linear relations among
wedges of rows of even parity yield the
near relations among wedges of rows of
odd parity so what I mean by wedge so
give it a vector space the sort of
second exterior power of that vector
space is basically the vector space
given by quotient out the tensor if it's
vetrix with itself by the skew symmetry
relation and it has basis which is sort
of these wedge products of basis vectors
of V so explicitly if we have some some
vector from V and another vector from V
so the NW then the wedge has
coefficients in this new basis which are
basically just these two by two miners I
was talking about
in particular the NW are linearly
dependent if and only if their wedge is
0 so going back to the original example
we have these r 0 0 0 0 0 at 1 1 1 1 and
if this wedge product vanishes then it
implies that the corresponding linear
combination of wedge products of the odd
rows also vanishes consider another
example say we have the following linear
relation among these two wedges just
some random wedges and now we consider
sort of all the possible pairs of
intermediate rows so you know all zeros
and all ones gives rise to all
combinations of you 11 and 3 ones
similarly 0 0 1 1 and 1 100 you sort of
look at all ways that you can swap out a
one with a 0 and a 0 with one you get
these four possible combinations and
basically I'm saying the mask I daddy's
imply that if you have this linear
relation among the even rows then you
have a linear relation among the odd
rows right so no need to remember the
actual match guy dennys anymore we serve
have this coordinate free interpretation
of the mask identities and this turns
out to be all that we really need so
first let me show why rank rigidity why
this the fact that the rank is all the
power of two implies that we always have
a cluster all right so say we have some
pseudo signature of size 2 to the L by 2
to the M and has ranked 22 the big K has
ranked equal to the domain size all
right and so we can we can furthermore
assume that this pseudo signature has no
proper clusters of rows which have the
same rank as itself if that were the
case then we can sort of replace our
pseudo signature with the sua signature
indexed by those that cluster of rows we
can replace this this L in the width by
this this new L prime which is the size
of the number of positions that this
cluster can vary on and we'll just
ignore everything outside of those
positions so all right so we can make
this assumption that if you've ever
index into a proper
cluster of rows the rank goes down
alright so inductively we know we have
some cluster of 2 to the K minus 1
linearly independent rows so let's just
say they look something like this you
have you know all zeros these are sort
of the fixed positions and these are the
positions in the cluster that are
allowed to bury right and so if we knew
that the fixed positions were only a
single position then we're basically
done because in that case you only have
2 to the K entries to work with we know
it's a rank 2 to the K so the cluster is
just the entire matrix system so let's
assume to the contrary that we have more
than one position that is fixed and now
let's say you know we have in total 2 to
the K not just choosing k minus 1 but 2
to the K linearly independent rows
suppose one of the other ones so we
still have 2 to the K minus 1 linearly
independent rows to account for suppose
one of them were this you know something
with a 0 among the fixed positions well
if that were the case now consider the
cluster where this position is all is
always equal to 0 well now we have a
proper cluster where the rank is 2 to
the K minus 1 plus 1 so by rank
virginity if we look at that cluster we
actually already have 2 to the K
linearly independent rows so
contradiction to our original assumption
so where do the two to the K minus 1
remaining linearly independent rows have
to be they have to be the ones where the
fixed bits are all equal to 1
and so now how does any other row in
this matrix fit into here well it has to
be in the span of the first cluster
because if you look at this position if
you look at the cluster where this this
bit is equal to zero then it's going to
give a proper sub for sub cluster with
rank equal to the rank of the original
matrix which is a contradiction it must
also lie in the span of this cluster for
the same reason if you look at this bit
and look at the cluster corresponding to
that bit being set to 1 you again sort
of get this contradiction so in
particular any other row has to lie in
the span of these vectors as well as
these vectors in other words has to be 0
and simplify mashpee identities we find
that this vector and this vector are
linearly dependent coffee addiction so
that's why rank rigidity implies cluster
existence and now how do we show this
rank rigidity I probably only have time
to work through the base case but
hopefully this gives idea of how these
match godís are used all right so the
thing I want to show is that you know if
I have a small Souter signature with
rank at least 2 to the k plus 1 then in
fact it's rank is going to be a power of
2 it's going to be 2 to the k plus 1 in
the exponent okay so how do we show this
well let's let's do a toy example so
inductively again we have some cluster
of 2 to the K and we want to show so I
denote by you know things that we know
to be linearly independent I do note in
red and we know we know we have at least
2 to the k plus 1 linearly independent
rows so outside of this cluster we also
have some let's say some vector 1000
that's the
and I want to basically fill up this
entire picture by showing but everything
can we call it a grid at that everything
is linearly independent if that's the
case then then we're done so let's let's
focus on this vector for now this this
index so in this row I claim that this
is also linearly independent of these
red rose and I'm going to use the sword
wedge product idea so suppose the
contrary that this this in dec this row
in this box lay in the span of the red
rose well now let's look at the wedge
product of this with the 0 the all zeros
row and if it's in the span of the red
rose then you know for some linear
combination of these wedges this
equation will hold but what is the match
key identities what did the match get
any tell us they tell us that this wedge
corresponds to the wedge of 1000 and
0001 we sort of swap out this 140 this
140 and so the left hand side sort of
corresponds to this and the right hand
side corresponds so we take any sigma
which is indexing a red even row
you see that you only ever have zeros in
the first position so the magic identity
sort of tell us that if this linear
relation held then there's some linear
relation among these wedge products of
odd rows if there are a leader a shin
among the even rows the wedges of even
rows then there's a linear relation
among the wedges of the odd rows but in
particular because these are linearly
independent these red rose then this
means sorry this should say rose if
there's a relation if the red rose are
linearly independent then the wedges of
them are going to be linearly
independent so we actually have a
contradiction and this 1001 must lie
outside the span of the red rose all
right so now we can mark that as red and
we can continue and let's say suppose
the contrary 1010 is in the span of the
red rose now that means we also have a
we would have our linear relation as
follows where we're wedging with the all
zeros row and we play the same game
right so by magic identities this wedge
gives rise to this wedge of Ian Rose
gives rise to a wedge of odd rows and
same here and if we compare these we see
that there can't possibly exist in
linear relation among all these rows and
so 1010 also doesn't lie in the span of
the road trip so we can also mark it as
read and so proceeding I don't want to
bore you with the details but proceeding
in this way we can basically show that
all the roads can be marked as read
alright so that's the base case of rank
rigidity and see so I'm not sure if I
have time to go over the inductive step
but I guess I'll say a bit about why
this floor function arises so what
happens we've only considered the case
of domain sizes that are powers of 2 in
all the other cases a result of who and
young basically we can adapt to show
that cases where the domain size isn't a
power to reduce the cases where it is a
power of 2 so they basically show that
over domain size 2 if you have a
holographic algorithm
which uses the basis that is a rank 2
and you already have a basic claps
theorem over domain size 2 then the same
claps theorem holds in the rank 2 case
more generally show that if you have a
collapse there over domain size are and
you have a basis matrix which is a rank
R then the collapse theorem over domain
size r carries over into the rank our
case and so in particular you know by
rank rigidity the standard signature we
already know has a power of 2 ranked in
particular by this relation m was having
rank a power of 2 as well the space
matrix and so by this foo and yang
result we show basically that a collapse
theorem over domain size 2 to the K
implies one for a k which is not a part
of to some particular we get this floor
function so remaining questions you know
what happens we this entire time we've
operated under the assumption that we
have a match gate which is a full rank
signature and the question is what
happens if no such full rank signature
exists and thankies paper deals with
this to some extent and also the other
question is now that we have this
collapse theorem we can you know start
asking questions about holographic
algorithms over higher domains and
hopefully now that we restricted the
range of basis matrices that we have to
consider hopefully this understanding
the structural theory of match gates for
these higher domains can be more
tractable so in conclusion I like to
thank compressor valiant for advise me
through this project press otay for
copious help with earlier draft of the
paper under graduate fellowship for
supporting research and science
institute for inviting me
questions we've heard in previous talks
about the set of a fine signatures which
are deep never the case extractable for
non-planar csv do you think it would be
possible to use similar linear algebraic
techniques to show a collapse theorem
holographic algorithms based on payphone
signatures instead of basically I'm not
terribly there with that area but um
basically the the main point is that
this leverages these you know these
algebraic identities gets out some kind
of linear algebraic corollary so those
identities and if you have corresponding
ones for these at my signatures then
hopefully the same kind of idea will
work but if all this or just boiled down
to some combo and some linear algebra so
but
so it's very very naive but the on what
you call the unsurprising part of the
hard part is is this kind of coming from
like Shannon signal capacity because you
have these kind of predictable things
we're showing up is that is it the
intuition for the floor function or for
the long-term work auction you said was
surprising yeah yeah log to okay it
wasn't oh no something yeah so I guess
so um I guess earlier I was talking
about this idea so what I mean by
encoding colors by you know bits
corresponding to the basis sighs I was
basically saying you know in the in the
previous setting saying whether a wire
was you know true or false correspondent
to either omitting or including the
external node in the corresponding match
gay when you have a wider range of
colors you still want to somehow say
like each color corresponds to you know
removing some collection of external
nodes and so until you want like every
every color to be associated to some
subset of those notes and so you get
this to to the to to the block size
equals like this the range of color
second they can take on so that's sort
of where the encoding by bits comes from
yo yo slightly here so that they have
the application there in the impact yeah
so how so this is about automated search
for autographing L sort of behavior how
this gonna be um yeah yeah so I guess
the the utility of the classroom for the
original collapsing over domain size too
was that you you only really need to
serve stare at you know all possible to
two-by-two matrices over over some field
and you can sort of explicitly write
down like these equations that such
signatures and satisfy so if you're
willing to do the work for larger
matrices at least you serve restrict the
universe of basis makes you say you have
to consider but I guess as the domain
size goes up you know the dimensions the
matrices also go up but they're sort of
some limit now to what you could
consider
and this so match gates the only game in
town so so there are no after the main
scholar so while you seek reducing to
the main site to is the only game yeah
so I think at this point I guess maybe
professor sire was a valium you all the
same word on this but there I guess
there are like a few there's a dimension
one variety mentioned 0 variety of like
holographic algorithms over these higher
demain sizes but I think overall it's a
very like poorly understood area so yeah
those questions okay thanks